Justice Department and intelligence
officials have agreed to meet with
congressional leaders to review
classified data from the Russia
investigation now that follows a
high-level meeting with President Trump
it tried to defuse a tense standoff over
restricted information that Republican
lawmakers want to see president has
demanded an investigation of claims that
an FBI informant infiltrated his
campaign Paula Reid is also at the White
House Paula good morning good morning
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
in a deft political maneuver has managed
to avoid a showdown with President Trump
over his unprecedented threat to order
the Justice Department to investigate an
informant who had contacts with his
campaign the Deputy Attorney General
passed this issue
off to the inspector general's office
before the president could issue any
order and at a meeting here at the White
House yesterday it appeared that the
president was satisfied even though in
the past he has criticized the Inspector
General for being too slow in his
investigations and lacking actual
prosecutorial power officials also
agreed that a White House chief of staff
John Kelly will oversee a meeting
between top law enforcement officials
and some congressional leaders to review
classified intelligence on this issue
while the White House is trying to paint
this as a win we don't know a lot of
important details here including which
leaders will be there and what they'll
actually be able to view because over
the past several weeks congressional
leaders and justice officials have met
but the Justice Department has fought to
protect the informants identity and
refuse to release documents to
congressional leaders leaving both sides
highly unsatisfied but as for now it
seems the Deputy Attorney General has
managed to de-escalate the situation
amid these rising tensions between the
White House and Special Counsel avoiding
a constitutional crisis for now Jon
Paula read for us at the White House
Thank You Paula